I don't want to be called an actor I
don't want to be called a star I don't
want to have a label I want to have a
legacy I want to be known as someone who
has goals and achieve and whatever they
might be wherever they might be I want
to be limitless I want I want to break
stereotypes I want to go where no man or
woman has gone before
and it might be a scary path and it
might be a path that no one's taken but
at least it'll be just mine
I had the worst self-esteem when I was a
kid I was made fun of because we had
talked well because of where I came from
I was made fun of on every level and the
only way you can change that is setting
goals for yourself and saying I will be
the best version of me when I was 18 and
I started doing movies I gave myself a
year and a half and I said if I don't if
I sense that I'm not good at what I'm
doing and I don't see something opening
up for me I'm gonna go back to college I
always had a plan B I still always have
a plan B and that's what I always tell
young people you know life doesn't end
it just keeps moving you have to put
your blinkers on and find what you do
best and just keep moving beautiful
Indian girl it's an easier fit and
decided never to do it but as I'm doing
a movie which I'm not the side chick and
the main villain of the movie you know
which is a different like who Devi was a
villain it's my first tape you could be
on film and in fact this but it's to
mean that strikes me as exciting I don't
like being conventional but I was trying
to put into that box so much that was
the first place I was put into all the
movies that came to me was that in fact
Baywatch I was being spoken to for
another part but the exotic you know
gorgeous pretty girl in amazing clothes
is so the fit of where people tried to
put me and I hope that doesn't happen to
anyone else coming in and out because
I'm huge even of the photo cut we need
to stand as a force to reckon with
we need to not be afraid to stand our
ground on our feet and say I'm not
settling and I hope that Indian talent
comes there and do that and I hope me
being in the position of position that I
am in can give them the confidence to do
it you just watched two amazing clips
from Priyanka Chopra take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]